Hello everybody and welcome to your first section of stop fighting cancer and start reading the cause this short little video every little section is going to have just a short little video obviously this is just an intro to the book that's my little picture down there in the corner
I thought you'd rather look at a slide with some information and stare at me while I'm explaining this so
this is the book you're downloading I wrote it several years ago and like I said in the first video that you watched we offered it as a free download we've had we've sold thousands of copies we've offered it as a free download and had thousands and thousands of downloads from people all over the world
and that honestly troubled me it troubled me because how are we going to ever help these people and when you write a book you put a lot of information in there and I have experienced with people with cancer that they seem completely overwhelmed
they're hit from from and who tells them to take this and and uh Uncle Bob's second cousin twice removed is telling him to do this and they got people stopping at church and telling him to do this it becomes just overwhelming and sometimes it's really easy because of fear to throw everything alternative out I'm just going to do what my doctor tells me to do and it's and we live in this
state of overwhelm that that's not good for our body when we're in a sympathetic fight or flight state that's not good for stopping cancer growth so with this I decided to change it instead of give it a free book download I want to give a free little MIDI course I know it's uh it's going to be a little bit better than the book download because I chopped the book up into this
and I want to give you a short video like this just to give you a little help along the way know that there's a person behind the book a clinic behind the book that we're here for you so in this first section it's just an introduction why I wrote the book that way stop fighting cancer is really important to me you have to get out of that fight or flight mechanism even in a sense of I'm going to beat this thing I'm going to fight cancer and I'm going to fight cancer
if we just relax calm down and and know that God is in control and he has a purpose in my life even with this cancer there's a purpose in my life and if we could get to see what the causes and treat that and be able to turn it over into his hands we're going to have the greatest success where I see patients with the greatest success is not so much that they did everything I told him to do
but so much that they were content in their decision about their approach they trusted that they have a heavenly father that is going to guide them and lead them and give them wisdom along the way so in this section you're going to get some definitions what's the purpose of conventional oncology why we treat the cause and we're going to start to uncover the the
four pillars that we base our practice on so there's four major pillars that we want to uncover with any patient even if they don't have cancer but certainly with cancer the first pillar is what's the what's the cause by Tanglight has been from the beginning of my practice is that there's always a reason why and that I think it's foolish just to simply give a diagnosis for the sake of giving it away
to the diagnosis there's too many people that are content with a diagnosis oh now I know what I have I have this Latin name that means this collection of symptoms that's not what we want there's a reason why we have a disease process and cancer is no different than that there's a reason why I have cancer
many times it's a biological toxin like a virus or bacteria or fungus or mold many times it's a chemical toxin like a pesticide or a old vaccination or a heavy metal toxicity there are ways to uncover that we do that with every member in our office there is a cause and we want to uncover that cause so we're going to go through this slowly read this section of the book that you have
and just meditate on it and above all just be praying for wisdom as you go through it each section you're going to get another one in a couple days is going to have a short little video like this that will help you
and then read the section if you always if you have any questions call our office talk to Jane or Janelle or myself and we'll help walk you through some things
all right God bless I will see you in the next section